st
yeah
oof barely got my headphones on for
that one i was still eating as
i'm sure my macedonian friend lauren very
calmly tearing apart at a ten yellow
dream was it's the cheesiest literally
i don't know
huh it wasn't a bull it's somebody
who's gonna shine but it's a small
an orange citrus fruit with with a
membrane it's a small as this is
the only difference between a golf ball
actually yeah a clementine and you know
an orange just the size size flavor
colors of oranges
robust flavor profile citrus column lands and
blends hey what's different between ah nectarine
and large ah did you tell me
size flavor color if you're nasty what
did the joker na sensitive these days
my freedom of speech freedom freedom of
speech
welcome to the show this is three
very special day
today god god's birthday oh boy you're
gonna continue the round you're saying it's
fair especially yeah i'm just very slow
it's a very special day guys it's
got a very hey yeah this very
special router works
so it's your day yeah i'm on
when you wanna talk about oh yeah
let's oh okay first of all i'm
paul i'm laura i'm scott i already
introduced myself birthday and it's my birthday
today if your birthday was you're listening
to this when it comes out it
it was ah you know it's my
friday whenever you're listening quite a while
ago um yeah birthday because it's your
birthday we're gonna let you decide what
we talk about first all right ah
oh boy yeah man please spy play
like as the webs in his hands
he says fucking talk about your past
five birthday overhead yeah
yeah i was thinking about this today
i can't remember too many of them
i remember one i had just established
you don't give a shit yeah i
don't you don't care ainu bed memory
true probably both of these are very
true um i do remember one was
star wars themes and my mom there's
a couple of years ago yeah
my my mom made a darth vader
cake and i remember she was at
the real darth vader of a fake
kick it was it was inside a
cake and just as i was saying
and using eat me he came out
he was like happy birthday mister president
the jayanthi
happy birthday
um but you made it out of
a cake pan that was a bell
she she was like well this isn't
a waste because i can also make
a cake that's a bell sure whichever
one needs
nation's birthday i was thinking about that
this morning i was like when did
she ever make the bell cake though
but i guess she must have made
it for like christmas like christmas bells
or whatever maybe or she just never
did but it's that thing you tell
yourself about where it's like to save
money yeah this is not a waste
of money so i won't resent my
child yeah
but yeah bell could have cost i
know well when you were little what
ten cents
that's actually not far off probably um
i mean every i i saw ah
you know my my father once told
me that the seniors i'm sorry it's
killing me because i'm the oldest nah
we always make buying this and it's
somehow due to my
a relationship with coop as well it
is part of that and she's not
young anymore either she is usually child
bride you are no elderly she's twelve
year a hundred when you were born
in the hay penny was a lot
of money
my father once told me that the
sign of getting old is when you
have like inflation sticker shock when everything
the price of everything is like upsetting
to you um
because you remember when you were younger
and you're like this shouldn't cost so
much and i felt that the other
day this is bad but i saw
a ah homeless person or a person
in need and they were like hey
you got a dollar and i was
like a dollar because i remember mean
i it give you twenty oh please
please not today not today it is
my birthday i don't want it on
my birthday because that'll mean it's for
my birthday i just wanted on any
other day so what did ah a
person without a home want from you
when you were growing well i quarter
know back in the day it was
like you have java nickel do you
have a nickel even people were like
pennies
back in the day but now and
i remember like scrounging up enough pennies
to get like one gallon of gas
um and now everything's just so expensive
anyway so there you go you are
old and because you're upset about it
i feel that way though about things
i'll be like i'll be like a
coke for two dollars three one dollar
i remember when kotaku your quarters
what can you still get all wet
and you still get them in bulk
for like a six pack for two
dollars or whatever no two dollars i
don't know you used to be able
to get like a coke for thirty
cents like on the average if you
bought a twelve o from like of
any machine no like no no from
anybody like anywhere health coach from vending
machines vending machines all right here
funny that some of you
it's been a machine spinning you got
a you haven't been mitchell played nice
rebate
he's been a machine at um where
i went to theatre school and we
learned that trick where you could like
tip it over yeah shake all the
stuff out and we did it so
much because we were so broken so
hungry all the time and that was
the only food anywhere and we would
do it so much that adventure anywhere
any time i guess we lived in
a dystopian future
well actually we did live we didn't
go to school right stupid and it
was next to a cost of seventy
but it's too to the point where
i think costco how long has costco
been around
i only heard about it in decades
and decades really because i just had
never heard about it till i was
like an adult i don't know if
we're wrong well why would you care
why would you care because materials didn't
shop in bulk so i guess i
wouldn't need to know is what you're
saying no i mean it's not the
most fun place to go as you
personally wouldn't be something that's on your
radar because you wouldn't go there like
i didn't know about a carburetor until
i was you know sixteen and had
oh i did i posted something on
my wall why does sexiest ones why
does it make me miss farrah fawcett
bohemia that's like i was going to
say why does it make me think
of gummy worms but i think it's
carnauba wax
why does that make me wait is
that the think of food though is
it like it's incoming various carnauba carnauba
wax yeah
um do do to to oh you
know one of my favorite birthdays was
two years ago back when we were
in hawaii yeah we're great we live
in a firewire works we bought we
we got there to hawaii and our
friend tell john we were driving to
dinner he's this was on my birthday
proper
we are ironic we were driving to
dinner and i'd be here he saw
a fireworks stand any insisted we pull
over we pulled over and then they
had some deal going on where it
was like yeah but if you buy
one it's cheaper if you buy three
because you get them all it's like
bi-weekly two parlors yeah they really wanted
to move these so
mark yeah well they're the least fun
firework of all it was almost fourth
of july yes so we bought just
packs upon packs of sparklers and we
couldn't even get rid of we left
them there for them there and then
you know who was in our ah
in the house that we rented was
chrissy teigen and john legend's right now
the makes us sound so rich but
we're not but where
we were surprised that they were yeah
yeah we were like what you were
doing well but then well no they
weren't splitting it with ten friends
that's true it was them and their
private chef when ah when cool i've
worked with them we wanted her to
ask them were there any sparklers there
to see just if like they carried
over because they were there in december
i think just to see if like
they got passed down to every generation
yeah that day when we were doing
the detective work to figure out if
it was the same house was a
lot of fun yes because i posted
on their instagram sardine i think fate
was the first to figure it out
yeah and then she she and
it was like from all angles we
were like we were like looking in
instagram going enhance that it's a lot
of screencaps and zooming in
and yes it was the exact same
huh was excited i wanna go back
i think i want to go back
i think about that so nice it
was so nice that was that was
what i think that was maybe what's
that my favorite vacation it might have
been oh yeah you know what it
really did for me was gave me
an appreciation for a relaxing vacation they
typically
i like to go to a city
and walk around the line yeah and
do up and pack a lot of
stuff in yeah and this was like
just chilling there's nothing to do in
hawaii yeah so it's you just something
to see that's for sure
you to your tie dye did like
your inbox viv yeah
but i really enjoyed how peaceful it
was it was a great location it
was great food it was a great
house yeah
i feel that i can yeah great
people i know what you're doing god
and all told you because it's your
birthday thank you my dad keep the
hawaiian islands straight like i've been there
multiple times and i never know which
island oman will there's a way orleans
and i also saw the medium island
what's that the small island and the
teeny tiny oh yeah really
is with me you gotta let him
have lenses
his birthday is this episode i can
do anything i want yeah oh no
um i don't know there's well no
because i used to worry wow my
ah honeymoon where we do for our
thing we were on the big island
yeah which is oha which is hawaii
right because i believe it's a well
my guess i don't know and i
feel like an idiot because it's not
that can you
oozing but i orange
where were you i just now was
on the big island
but i couldn't figure out but i
was and i was saying at ah
at the same resort though you were
at but i couldn't figure out i
thought we had stayed there and it
turned out we were on a different
island is my whole point i was
like well i was looking around for
the house like i was being like
oh wait you were on a totally
different island but it was the same
my phone charger same resort chain
nw yeah but i don't know what
island we were i think we were
on a not on the big island
really is this going to sound the
dumbest conversation that worked in young yeah
it is
it's it's so great when you've been
to hawaii so many times you don't
even know what i know i know
i've i've been like four times but
i've never known where i am right
i went to maui the first time
i reached my goal in chloroform i'm
like bieber because i just don't get
it i can't keep it straight i
mean what are they trying to do
and they all
the same but instead i would say
they would say that's not true people
who know do you remember when we
got class shamed at the luau way
no right yeah see the lady who
was charles lew oh yeah oh who
said we're all ohana now yeah we're
always busy so we're all along so
if you're this is how you treat
ohana don't lazy martin she
he said how many people are here
for the first time and a bunch
of people is like applaud yeah she
said how many people are here for
the second time and some people clap
said how many people have been here
three times or more and and then
a number of people clapped including us
all the way before right that many
times and she said those
or our rich friends yeah forgot we
always say it was like damn
you live here don't you want us
to come here maybe not they don't
actually save enough a lot of um
a lot of hawaiians ah seem to
hate the people from the main land
who come in and make it like
you know bad yeah right but you
but i'll say i blame them oh
no i know but i have to
say everyone
i ever encountered and countered there was
very nice yes i of some of
my family comes from there and still
lives really yes your wham
ah it's too hard to explain my
dear but i won't get into it
today but ah so will be from
hawaii yeah so when i went the
first time i went to maui and
then we went you know we were
at the heart and my brother got
married i think of the four seasons
or whatever there and then we went
up but then whenever it was the
two seasons
and now it's wrong then whatever season
we went up into the hills which
you don't really ever go you know
like driving in the wind in the
middle of maui you know and where
to wear a relative lived and it
was interesting because no one ever you
know would go there when you're on
vacation yay yeah it was interesting yeah
i love
of seeing where locals live because it
is very cool like the eye it
makes you think it would be the
most beautiful place in the world to
actually what's all by that house didn't
we look into it
did we i think we all looked
at how much it was and were
like i mean we've had ten of
us but then we forgot we're all
couples it's like let's split it up
ten ways oh wait no it's actually
five points
i like when you go to hawaii
and if you know someone who lives
there though they'll take you through the
doors we can go behind it yeah
behind hawaii yeah i said yeah it's
like a secret passage still a break
rooms and stuff it's like truman show
it's like truman show sly hey truman
truman show up i think that your
life is that
that
no tv show was watching what's your
favorite birthday lobby a favorite birthday home
i always had really fun parties when
i was little teufel birdies yeah and
um my mom and my uncle would
put together um themed parties fame like
the global idea of big seventies party
and the tramps would be there no
remember that fewer eleven years old you
loved disco
me and my front yard with like
oh there was one that's a notable
well there are a few i guess
one okay so i just found my
home movies and got them oh transferred
and i was able to watch them
and one of them was a manners
party where my mom is a maid
and my uncle is a butler and
they are teaching us manners and i'm
probably like
like seven or something this is the
most insidiously oh my god we look
so bored like i remember no k
i know and i remember thinking many
things about it but i'm sure i
was thinking like cooler you know whenever
i was a kid but then i
looked at the video and i was
like and i couldn't even like
listed like it was like so boring
was it about silverware or yeah and
then like stuff walking with a book
on your head a lot like what
were the i don't know and then
there wasn't some fun at all no
i i know it's so strange and
then another one i think they were
having fun but that was
no doubt and another one was aladdin
themed his aladdin had come out recently
and was a gypsy and my uncle
was like i don't know no like
a gypsy man or something yeah they
were wearing like one of the romani
yeah um
and that was supposedly fun and then
ah i did another one that was
that was mostly fun i don't know
if this was somebody else's party or
this is known party but i was
a heroine dalmatians party where we um
ah
pay our facebook and then i got
tails with spots on which was a
tube sock with black spots huh
but but yeah i like cute parties
they were very themed um and then
when i got older more i would
just have like house parties and stuff
i remember i was thinking of a
party today that i had on halloween
when i got into seventh the seventh
grade i got a bunch of new
friends right and my parents went all
all out i'm thinking about this probably
because i had new friends and they
wanted me to impress them or whatever
and we have this halloween party where
it it was like everyone dressed up
and there was a cauldron where we
bobbed for apples and there was like
a murder mystery element to it and
i remember many things i remember you
get apples you get the murder mystery
and get both
i remember my friends and me suddenly
feeling embarrassed because we were i could
feel we were too old for it
yeah and i felt so bad that
my parents went to all this trouble
and suddenly like i felt embarrassed for
them that they were trying too hard
and i felt embarrassed for myself like
i seem
i'm like a kid and then that
was the last theme party i think
i ever had oh yeah that was
not a thing when i was growing
up party or where i grew up
teams it was just like it it
like mostly what i remember is having
um just like dinner with the family
and it's like i got to have
whatever i wanted from the nurses and
oh several it was a courses party
so i guess it was a theme
ah but like if you went to
a friend's house for their party it
was just like yeah it would take
would be the the theme yeah exactly
play yeah it was just played with
like yeah your little school friends and
everything you write making ice cream
yeah that's i guess usually house did
not get like the the person whose
birthday was they got presence but nobody
else did they were not like party
favors and china yeah that's usually how
it was i think you'll like most
you'd have a pinata or something and
people would or a slip and slider
whatever but i think the star wars
one was just i don't think anyone
was encouraged to dress up
star wars it was just it was
the star wars cake yeah you know
it was like actually i think i
asked for action figures i should hold
they were on and they were on
the cake i think but the halloween
is a theme i mean you can't
have a helloween party and not the
theme not be halloween yeah exactly yeah
exactly but i'm proving your point wrong
huh
ah that you did that there weren't
theme parties like there were home robberies
for first-day alright yeah sure i'm pushing
it birthday boy i still you gotta
take it guy got a t-shirt i
remember i had a bowling part of
my first coed birthday party was fifth
grade and i had a bowling coating
cooperatively educational yes and um only one
boy came ooh who's this doe john
kim john kim really right and was
happy to be there was it yeah
but i was i remember being um
did the boys all boycott did they
put the boycott i don't know why
they didn't
come but i remember as it was
like getting close i knew they weren't
going to did someone say something like
we're not going to your nobody was
like an rsvp situation where i was
like oh i guess they're not coming
in then i was like maybe they
made john kim the ambassador yeah me
boy ambassador but isn't that sad when
like say your greetings from the boys
isn't it also though
though like is it a thing where
like we can't go to lawrence birthday
because that's a girl party maybe because
it was rid of that time where
it was because we were having a
guy i don't know if other people
had boy girl parties at that point
rise ten know i did but i
don't even think that maybe it wasn't
even a thing of it to be
boy girl not boy girl is just
who you were friends with and i
guess i was
i'm really friends with a lot of
women until three weeks ago yeah
when i'm in three weeks i became
friends with a guy alive my wonderful
lady ga ga blue built um
i had a birthday party a birthday
dinner in my thirties that was just
me and six women oh wow and
i because i'd seem my worn out
once i was
seen a porno you know what i
want maybe i go to their clothes
um i i've been to dinner at
a gym or you know el coyote
that i'm beverley yeah of course i
play i actually i miss that place
i was out dinner with friends there
next to us was this i love
it i miss that terrible place yeah
the food was never there's something very
calming about just going to it and
getting a margarita in that first place
yeah i've been in a while
go back the the table next to
us was this long table and it
was all these women and it took
us forever to realize there was one
dude was sitting with all of these
women oh wow and we never really
found out what the situation was but
i took a picture of them i
still have it and i said i'm
gonna do that for my next birthday
i'm gonna have i'm gonna invite all
my women
friends oh wow and then it will
just be me and your single yeah
yeah that was when i was just
starting to when jane and i were
just beginning courting oh interesting and there's
a picture of us it's guy it
was janie there yeah wish you no
okay janie was there and everybody said
like all of the all of the
other women there um later
i said we could tell that you
were in love with her ah she
was the last one to arrive i
think we saw your face change oh
yeah wish i could see that face
yeah you just never know
you never will
that's so nice
ah wow i think birthday dinners i
was thinking about this like ah because
cool op used to have a lot
of them when we first started dating
like the did i have i talked
about this about birthday dinners being a
thing when you're young it's yeah we've
talked about that before and you're like
you celebrate every single year yeah and
then you gather whomever is your friend
that year
oh yeah and it changes every year
yeah need to come to your house
for the birth they didn't do well
to go to a restaurant yeah it's
like yeah we've made a reservation for
twenty people and how do we divvy
up the check because we're all broke
because we're all twenty yeah oh those
kind of things yeah we're somebody or
an adult now when your parents are
you're saying like yeah thanks remember you
know when you're like your know anyway
yeah twenty yard college or whatever
if there was somebody in our friend
group who notorious backup back in those
days when we used to do those
dinners everything notoriously was cheap and we
always had to put an extra money
to cover this person right i don't
and it was fucking annoying i feel
like in a group setting thinking you're
getting away with that is strange because
people yeah tell so i've you know
what's even stranger not caring yeah apologize
if i can't afford it yeah i
ask you who that is when we
will take a break but i had
a friend like that who would always
tip ten percent and ah and it
was very very embarrassing for me but
i would try to sneak by
back and i had a bringing that
to leave extra money yes but then
i was talking to my other friend
the other day and he was like
ah he was talking about a mutual
friend of ours and he was like
every time we would go out to
dinner
i would leave a good tip like
twenty percent and then he would like
come back to the table look at
it and throw an extra like ten
on it or whatever and it would
just drive me crazy yeah teams like
being very judgmental of the person who
paid it right did sneak back and
do it sure you know maybe twenty
percent i feel like you're human
or in front of it yeah you
would do it in front of him
as as like this is not enough
kind of thing i don't know i
have a reputation of this diner
so what can call me deep buckets
will confer about this in the break
about who these people are
yeah yes ma'am
learn did you ever wait tables lauren
did you know i worked um as
a barista and quotes for like a
couple of days i've seen quotes because
i didn't know what i was doing
and i was horrible i wouldn't give
myself the title of that you're not
worthy i'm not i am trying schwing
not worthy schwing
oh man whenever they should write exactly
um
excuse me yeah i wanna see i
was um determined to get a job
immediately and a friend of mine fashion
magazine yes i had to have it
yeah a friend of mine was working
at this um cafe in near where
was it um right near strand bookstore
near union square of course i know
that because i read constantly yeah you
know that about you um and i
got what he basically hooked me up
with the job
job and i got i i got
it and then i had just and
i was really excited because my two
roommates didn't have a job yet and
i was like look i got a
job faster than anyone like i'm doing
it and then i had to do
the job so that was a bad
part boiling and i like to go
train and i had to train it
like fi it was dark when i
left the house which were how
was by the way i lived in
like a cube but it was very
um it was like already a lot
just to get up that early and
take the train into the city i
was living in brooklyn and then like
go and and do it and open
the gate with the guy and then
this person would teach me what positive
mark marron ah yeah open the gates
and then they this they're very nice
people who work there all like sketch
comedians um from murder fist worked there
if anyone knows who do we got
dana carvey will ferrell cheri oteri our
work there caesar
anyway i was really horrible i don't
drink coffee and i don't know anything
about it so i was like trying
to learn whatever drink was and then
how to make it and then in
new york as in many big cities
everyone's rushing in they know because i
go there every day and they know
what they want and and everyone else
there's really good at doing that and
i was like really stressed out i
think i only really i trained a
few days
i think i actually only worked like
did you get fired or were you
like ok i am a lose i
quit i
i was so stressed out by i
would go home and just think about
it the whole time i was home
like i can't go back there when
you yelled at a lot by people
of like come on hon and probably
but like it's all a blur the
big thing to me was like i
just can't go there i can't do
this i don't the idea of going
there is hell and just the fact
that i have to go again makes
every
living moment horrible like i write this
is bad how long did you last
a few days and then i called
and they really spread out but it
was like the torture of my mind
and then i called and quit and
the woman was like not cool about
about whatever but i still wanted to
get my hundred dollar check that i
had and that was really embarrassing because
i had to go in and like
yeah go in yeah yeah oh you
needed it
i would have mailed it to know
there was never even but she's you
can come and get it yeah it's
probably just being bitchy i never even
consider that i could get mailed but
she was definitely inconveniencing you on purpose
yeah i had a very similar situation
when i was in filling and starting
standup i lived with my girlfriend at
the time my day job i've had
in the belfry briefly went away because
the store
it closed down for what to many
bats in the hats yeah in the
belfry yeah the basket confused and they
thought they belonged there hey this is
betsson the rendering all that
and then people got scared because it
had just flying that would be so
cute
it would be cute if the hats
were small enough for the bets sure
sure if that's a big you don't
think about how he's nodding around his
cute the hats fly around his cute
that's cute yeah so either way it's
good
so i had to get a job
and i went and applied at this
at this coffee shop and independent coffee
shop um downtown which is like a
real it was an area where like
there was very high traffic a lot
of business people um and so even
though i had no experience in anything
like
this has never worked in any kind
of food industry at all was always
retail you you did you drink coffee
though unlike lauren no i didn't you
didn't okay and so basically the job
was it was me and the owner
of the shop owner of the shop
oof
she would hope she would would you
say let your stomach which i said
would you say lauren it's my birthday
would you say happy birthday
she would be baking baked goods the
entire time and i would be at
the register doing everything else oh and
so the training was very enough people
it's not it's not yeah and the
training was very brief and very this
lady was very ah um very terse
fs and she was not friendly and
i was at that point too scared
i i was at a at a
place where where i was for most
of my free workout if i didn't
yeah it was coward if i didn't
know something i didn't understand something i
would not speak on it right right
i would think like oh i don't
wanna i don't wanna seem dumb yeah
hopefully this will just come to me
yeah yeah yeah but they didn't
right and the register i did not
know how to work it people would
give me it was not it was
not one of those registers that would
automatically take her the math for you
yeah and so um people would give
me aut amounts too because they wanted
a certain change back yeah so i'm
i'm gonna do math in my head
the more anxious i got the the
more i could not do mathematics
yeah it was bad news she kept
she kept having to come help me
out she was not just johnny well
i know but she was not oh
so at the end of the and
also i had to get up like
in the dark to go to this
place yeah when it opened at six
and that's any coffee place yeah so
i got songs i got home from
a full day's work you
you know but like whatever it was
two o'clock or something like that right
and i got back into bed and
i said i don't
i don't think i can go go
back there and my girlfriend said listen
if it's that bad don't go and
i'm like no i have to go
i have to go because you know
i need to work she's like if
it's that bad don't go and it's
like i have two then the next
day when the alarm went off at
four thirty i said i can't do
that she goes are you sure
ah jeez lucas now they know you're
thanking you yes exactly you're also in
a relationship where it's always hoping signs
she's working and i'm not working no
but it's it's one of those things
where it's like you and i've been
in relationships where like where like no
matter what the issue you feel like
you have to take the opposite side
of it you know what i mean
so it's like i got to go
back well don't
if you don't want to and then
alright i'm not going back are you
sure you're not going back i don't
know if that was this i think
this was i think she was being
very sweet to me when i was
completely demoralized but still willing to go
with emasculated and of course a masculinity
well there was another guy there watching
you cook yeah
it was a weird relationship don't you
think you'd be if i've said this
too but i feel like i could
be really good at that right now
because i've like gained con feel yeah
i'm slightly good at any job yeah
i feel like i can anyway so
good yeah right store now because i
like how confident i was great at
retail yeah it was really great i
was also good to tell a marketing
and telemarketing job once that was the
absolute where i was really good and
i was great at it i got
salesman of the month cause i'm very
much and i think that would be
better because you are not seeing the
people face-to-face so if you are nervous
you're like i'm in my bubble and
if they hang up the hat i
think telemarketing would be bad now because
no one ever answers
their phones be right well yeah being
spammed yeah spamming order what your new
thing now i don't know but i'm
worried about my federal student loans i
don't know about my social security card
was cancer nusa literally over the last
two days so they've been spoofing you
know like wow is that what you're
that is
oh my they're like cats they're like
yeah their identity is like being
yeah so the new thing over the
last two days is now they call
from apple dot com right yeah one
is crazy i had to like tell
my mom don't and never ever give
your password for apple yeah over the
phone apple will never call you and
ask for that yeah that is never
a thing that they do its know
before you use
on another device call us yeah you
know it's just like insane we saw
you're trying to do a text it
must work right now i think a
lot of older older people are just
thinking yeah they don't know how to
use this stuff there was some story
i heard of some woman who was
um like that her money was don't
look like thousands of money was stolen
thousands
like winter bank account or something and
got like thousands of deaths where all
the body i know and it was
just gone that's just sad wait staff
well they like talk to over the
phone like for all long time for
you just went to the bank getting
ready to have all her money no
she just gave all her information to
eventually oh i know a date actually
like
i was helping my parents out with
some financial stuff a couple of years
ago and my mom had all the
stuff from the eir s and owe
them a ton of money and i
was like working working out with her
and but now i think about and
i talked to him on the phone
and everything but now i'm like
how do you know it was them
was it the ira's yeah like i
know we like wrote to them officially
and all that but like just the
fact that there's all this it's crazy
kind of makes me go like wait
a minute i'm a grown-up continue there
are so many websites that i feel
like are just too many untrustworthy but
then you have to give your information
it's like okay so i'm just supposed
to
assume that this is that everything's cool
yeah yeah
i know the the world we live
in
do would you give me your banking
passwords yes if i if if i
had a legitimate reason yeah i guess
i don't know why you could if
you had a legitimate reason sure but
i can't imagine what the reason is
but if you slipped
give me an hypothetical i y any
my password i knew my password you
don't want the money in it or
anything no i mean so why are
you any money will say this you
just need to know what's in there
you're obsessed
yeah your think this yelp says you're
mentally ill you have a problem you
know
i don't i don't want to take
anything out i'm certainly not gonna raising
yeah cheers okay can i have your
pass i just want to know what's
going on i want to look in
there just what's going on in there
i want yours to have it i
just want to like do i have
your own swipe and awake sure make
sure everything's cool i have your password
to your bank account i don't
even know my pastor to my maker
and you're assisting given to me you
psychopathic rich person ah
alexa what does scott ottomans network one
dollar
same as paul f tompkins i possibly
write that's right it feels good it
does feel good to be equals yeah
especially if you saw our houses oh
my god
they're both great they're both great they're
both great are my high waves um
hi why am i watching aunt live
from west virginia musical guest i was
huh
yeah um she
ooh some amazing shaded us because she
came to visit l a i needed
with those trees that were cut down
i was single all the trees my
very good very good guys words um
we were we were at dinner and
she's and she's a real character she
like does community theater in her in
her hometown and she
she is ah she's very funny and
she's a delight to be around but
she
she were out to dinner and she
was talking just to me and she
said your house is adorable and i
said oh thank you very much it's
so it's so lovely and i mean
how much room do you ne yeah
i'll come up first of all calling
her adorable is semi slow walks a
line if you're reminds me of carmela
soprano there was an episode where her
friend buys a house and she goes
and this is the house she goes
oh it's so cozy yeah cozy yeah
yeah yeah who is this person well
let's let me fuck her his aunt
phyllis she's wonderful like when you're looking
for an apartment on craigslist forever and
they write the thing like that where
it's like cozy studio
yeah whatever they try to like judge
it up a little bit even say
in the facts although cozy place is
cozy done right to me as long
as huh
but cozy is an automatically an insult
oh no it's like it it says
it says to me it's like oh
it's like mom cabin with rye fire
rosie don't ride fire wood our promise
to your fireplaces cosy done right yeah
alright we have to take a break
okay
and we're back for scott's birthday podcast
yeah birthday on the scene the number
one birthday day oh and by the
way you did sell your birthday to
me a while ago that's right where
are we celebrating way to them for
how much thousand a thousand did
ever gave him a thousand dollars now
so you would so do you want
to go in on it and by
his birthday i was actually thinking about
that today what and what were the
terms i could not celebrate it ever
and you guys anyone steady breath you
say go to hell or shut up
not explaining it yeah just purely good
it'll be kind of mean you can't
say it like it's funny right right
yeah okay but alright but you do
get to choose between those two phrases
yeah i feel like depending on the
age of the alternate it's gone up
a little bit good idea like the
price the price because you got to
taught sika thousand and fifty
prices like these i'm getting old so
if we back past extra i was
talking about those five guys burgers yeah
yeah please digger jacques birthday ziggurat
hi
oh shabby and a new joint character
doom mining like love the morning this
is different differences sunny jasmine my voice
is more pleasant as sunny do you
guys wanna come back on my special
guest i'm asking you on air so
that they know it's dicky alright i
wanna do
i wanna do that show us afraid
i wanna do that oh okay alright
cool i'm gonna do it all the
time oh well with special guests
you cow or when you see those
um yeah go back you wanna do
generations too that's what i'm thinking maybe
okay or like or like you know
should just be an unfair conversation by
the way we didn't have our unfair
conversation who is your didn't well it
was ammon who was who's moody identities
of these people the skin flint and
ah over chipper and the miser why
don't we just cut it out
and an emission through them
no okay
i don't write any indicator that he
was willing to do that no i
can't even see him you can't see
he's already there they're here there's gonna
run we got zig in the house
he's over here in the actual room
actual room chevron is wherever he goes
i'm sure he's out gallivanting around america
with scale fend probably kissing her kissing
her and hugging for the july plans
guys i know i know this was
last week this sound that sounded so
much like we've run out of yeah
it's possible what do you guys do
over the holiday there's always more to
talk about
but since it will be over by
now i'll say about time you hear
this i will say i'm going to
little compton rhode island for the fourth
of july i'm going to sullivan's island
south carolina for the fourth of july
i'll be in new york city just
like i pictured it wow
um do you feel like you're gonna
go see fire under rex i'm saying
do you know aren't due on the
fourth yeah they have those fireworks are
off the brooklyn bridge and so we
got a reservation at a hotel you
could see it from the hotel yeah
yeah we're just a dinner reservation where
they have like a big seafood buffet
and stuff and yeah you can eat
stuff from the sea yeah
yeah just like reach right in there
and you're like no fuck is it
every buffet is a seafood buffet because
you see food huh
how dare you look at me because
no because you know i you just
stared so blankly and i thought there's
no way he'll hold out and be
so he's got to look at me
like janie yeah when she walked into
that restaurant really genius
look janey on your birthday here's a
topic that i would i'm very i'm
very excited about this topic i thought
okay here we go this is about
an adorable thing that my dear cheney
started doing out of nowhere recently oh
my we will we make the bed
together frequently
oh because it's just like it's just
faster to do it that door everything
is faster it's a horrible chore but
if we do it together i love
having the bed made though it's coming
in at the end it feels amazing
but when we wash the sheets then
it's even more stuff that you have
to yeah yeah i try to force
me to do that with sheet he
does it i admitted sour cheetos i
want to say things like he's like
i
only play video games but i think
jamie would probably express it the same
way of me i'm bad for some
gonna help me i'm bad at making
the bed so that is a collapsing
yeah she does it by yourself every
time by yourself yeah wow it's not
that what are you bad are straightening
shoemakers away and identify showings okay she
used to be a major eighty has
very specific thing as well oh really
she hotels she used to be made
in hotels and so she's like it's
it's gotta be up to that level
like my my oh my father when
he wanted me to make the bed
he was trying to he would always
like make it be like the army
where he like if i can just
order off of it and it's like
it doesn't have to be this way
yeah like we're just normal people i
just don't see the way
for the army yeah yeah just to
show good discipline good man yeah yeah
um it's just a party
we all make our beds yeah well
make super tight ben i'm just gonna
hear this and i don't know what
she'll say we'll get a blanket bar
i
um so we were making she started
doing this a couple months ago out
of nowhere referring to the fitted sheet
as the curly sheet wow because it
curls up on the ends yeah i've
never heard this in my life no
she has never said she tried to
pass it off like it's a southern
thing like oh yeah
oh call the currently she is not
is that i don't find the word
for it no i don't i don't
know why she started she knows fitted
sheet yeah so she just decided she
said really cheap before she started saying
curly sheet and i i love it
it's so it's out of nowhere i
like it too do you fold your
curly sheet
um where where when you put it
away when you have extras you know
okay what was that cat dying oh
i see yes that sounds like a
carrot interesting yeah i heard something too
i don't know if it was from
weird ah was that was from out
there was it from zia did you
hired it i heard it did you
hear it i don't know
what it wasn't any of our phone
use dick did hear it zig heard
it zig was a u with my
computer though it hit your mike what
was it that was it what was
it i just heard it again oh
it's these microphones the mc stands but
he happened before he but nobody moved
to mike stand i go
oh okay just let it be it's
just a ghost you think it's a
cat ghost that's dumb
zucchini ones are those finish business you
know people with their ghost beliefs thinking
only people are ghosts was pretty self-centered
ego centric there are some real logical
there's snows there should be a ghost
every burdens ever lived if you're going
to have ever lived every american people
goes there's a revamp
a people get to be ghost birds
get to be ghost d a that's
the story i don't want to hear
anything more rowdy you almost hit a
rabbit with my card as on my
way here well because i hated it
because it jumped out and running away
over here really yeah i'm lucky birthday
but you can get the foot i
made it well i was kind of
like oh my god
well i would have had to have
pulled it like say it was not
dead i would have had to have
like pulled it over nursed back to
health with your teat
ha with my penis over the years
suck on this
you sell mats
he's sucking your dick on your birthday
oh the birthday okay
yes you so much exit picture like
this person went crazy on the birthday
out so so on and so on
from from the forearms is like birthday
bachmann
the names are getting a little out
of control i don't see him just
first-day hammerman that's right we have to
have a musical muncher i'm just saying
that's i'm just saying wish you had
something that people cared about i wish
i had some people care about anything
at all blows out candles man blows
out candles man i mean basically point
is just anything with man at the
yeah yeah yeah
okay so yeah yeah and you have
now anyone can play i have stuff
you're so jealous right now alright yeah
i guess i really wait it's pretty
ugly laura and i'm so sorry for
showing my tickler green plane to get
today for your boot planning to get
what you mean guidance i don't i
asked for no i said please don't
buy me presents
i don't even want to pray god's
kamala you don't want all present or
card no i don't think i didn't
even think about it i don't think
i'll get anything i'm sure cool i'll
give you spain i don't think mean
we're going out to dinner but do
you like when you say don't get
me something you both like no no
we get to that truly mean a
yeah okay for like christmas and stuff
it's like wow yeah we kind of
settled into a place well we get
each other stuff for christmas apples calling
me pula
put him on the volley yeah put
em on the phone
hello
calling me and calling regarding security thing
sounds like molly before any overt i
strongly recommend you to talk to a
guy there
nine here right now
please press one to connect press one
hello
hello warming morning
i hope you well there's this problem
with my apple device
well glad to show well what's going
on with my apple device
do they hang up they hung up
on me you fell for it too
hard
here's a problem with my apple that's
called ma'am no really oh nobody's machine
probably because fucking psychos there was an
episode tell i was too young to
there's an episode of reply all um
a podcast you know that podcasts when
they kind of like shoes don't bring
out the bad guys look hannah
if it's not three-time i don't give
a shit they'd better talk about us
rebuy rebuy all your we'll know you
listen to this one for us one
for you my i will say my
one complaint with replies is that they
often don't come to a conclusion they
just like presented onto facts and then
they're like anyway who knows they move
on i don't love that but i
do understand it's it's it's difficult to
solve everything
um but they did a thing about
that i don't know like solve they
they basically like that one was pretty
interesting they like called they like stayed
on they made a relationship with that
guy basically on the other right call
and like got to the bottom of
where the call was coming from and
what they were doing and how the
scam works and all that stuff well
we had a friend who's using who
was their social
media was being hijacked do you remember
this and they talked to the hijacker
who was like me a thousand bucks
oh dan yeah yeah damn dude we
talked about it and we talked about
oh okay yeah yeah danna dude and
he posted on instagram yeah yeah i
think it was even less than that
it was like some kid who'd oh
yeah this
this like podcast goes into stuff like
that to people hacking snapchats and stuff
yeah it was like give me money
and i'll give it back to you
and then dan was like come on
man and then he realised dan was
on one of his favorite shows as
a kid i played it for disney
show you know that on that and
was like serious was like well okay
well i'll give it back to you
but like let me let me teach
you how not this yeah cannot happen
to you again or he's like my
boss really wants me to do this
and then like his boss got involved
it was very weird i find that
we were over in his house while
this was happening and yeah i was
calling and it's that's so creepy yeah
i think it's fun i think it's
fun to try to trick people i
think it's fun to trick people if
we're lucky the magical trickster gods actually
thing
like you stuff that's exact low key
i don't think it's pronounced oh he's
just a low key low key the
magical just he's lowkey magical tricks does
it make you feel
you feel good to pretend you're better
than me pretend
yeah it makes you feel good
ah
wait what's an adorable thing that you're
that your people do my people oh
yeah what people your person what i'm
like oh curly curly sheets my best
friend sheath yes your best friend ah
oh bully well one thing that really
put me on this one thing that
is kind of ah
if i say it's a you that
is a strange question to ask point
blank yeah michael b to ah he'll
he'll be confused because i send mixed
signals about this
the blurred lines
ah but he is very obsessed with
chess at the moment and playing on
this app constantly with people he knows
and also with strangers and he keeps
ordering chess sets and you just got
like the fourth one in the mail
i thought it was a package i
ordered but it was another chess that
i was like this has to stop
he was like this last one
so that's what it's where
where does he put pluto well he's
like once for upstairs plants one jared
and yeah
ah i look everything she does is
cute i got nothing specific summoned she's
the youngest person ever seen everything's just
adorable
for baby because she's walking now that's
cute i'm walking now she's got two
tv
guys come on okay well am i
off the hook for your birthday for
everything you don't say anything cute
is he good at chess yeah i
mean i think so i don't know
how to play did he i don't
know how to play he's trying to
get me to play and that's been
a struggle because it's a bone of
contention i was already named a louisville
want to learn and then he'll be
like just sit down and move pieces
and i'll just tell you what you're
doing and what's wrong or whatever then
i'm like i'll tell you what you're
doing wrong
yeah and then like i was playing
and i'm just like willy nilly moving
them around and then he won and
then i was like k and then
you know it's like yeah fine it's
not really the um you know you
can well yeah and you can't play
against a person who plays all the
time he's willing to teach me i'm
just really unwilling to learn and i
think it is my fault it sounds
like a one hundred yeah
yeah i like i've thought about giving
in and then i'm like i really
don't want to it's just that thing
of like it's not like i'm gonna
be playing all the time yeah it's
also not like like playing someone who
plays scrabble every day and and then
allowing the person to have like the
two letter word list that they can
look at or or the dictionary or
whatever so they can get
it up to speed just like chess
it's like how do you i don't
know how i mean it's all just
very funny like we had our friend
mariah over and carry ah yes i
see let's say
let's say and he was like as
she was leaving his like joe pie
gestures like yeah then he was like
john panels like you can go like
it was like you i have cats
or any use ah like you are
you like to see if your shoes
don't worry um but i had to
like fight for it so he's he's
a big chestnut you just want someone
to play with and i
i mean yeah but now with online
you can tell he's playing constantly i
mean yeah anytime isn't this funny is
playing with many plays damning any plays
like a handful people on the ass
so he should just do that why
subject everyone who comes into your house
to that sky as they often give
in a lot of people are like
oh sure i'll play so then it's
like are you a black mirror yeah
lets people play in
person you want to talk to a
human being much like you in apple
inc
i love it's like apple incorporated yeah
oh my god this is official yeah
i also feel like if they were
calling an iphone it would just say
apple because they would have had that
figured out like they wouldn't have something
wouldn't do that course they wouldn't but
i'm saying like it should say apple
if you want to try to trick
me right well your phone's blowing up
i look as my birthday i feel
like i'm doing right yeah a lot
of
messages or something a lot a lot
of activity in the toy people thread
yeah yeah they're a ah an instagram
thread from post about you i don't
know that's what i'm worried about because
i was getting nothing which is great
like i like you prefer that i
prefer to be lowkey where it's just
like under the radar i like to
be low-key on my birthday too i
don't i like to be high key
birthday no kim but um oh yeah
i i like to get a lot
of posts but i worry about anything
cool i've just posted about it because
now suddenly i'm getting a lot of
stuff she must have yeah don't like
it she's like love my scotty yeah
so grey here's a cute thing you
did i can name a bunch of
them yoni anyway
let's go to a break okay
who are the cheapskates
happy
a
ah me
they just ate breakfast
yeah wow okay so if lorenzo's came
in lauren just came in with bowls
ah a full thing of whipped cream
and chocolate chips and she and by
the way shevlin just texted me wow
happy
earth day as as you did this
because on a previous episode i guess
i spoke about my desire as a
kid which which i never did if
eating just whipped cream with chocolate chips
guess because you did absolutely do that
she made me spit and and everyone
else special treats for my birthday oh
my gosh
i miss his cause
wow thank you thank you very much
wow all right so we're going to
do a taste test on this and
see if it's actually a good treat
okay ah i'm predicting that it will
be i'm predicted to get to so
we're all gonna ah we're all gonna
eat this one here here we go
absolutely
good yeah i wasn't crazy o two
three things together wow chow gonna whip
cream eleven in the morning
now that's well cool happy birthday scott
we love you yeah mardi finally got
it thank you for finally go up
your dream of eating that well they
did yes thank you so much and
so nice if you can keep wanting
more
um welcome back so it's time for
a three-term feature i also got this
birthday cake popcorn which isn't dry oh
thank you i saw it and i
thought well i'll take this to the
movie with me over vic um zug
said you add ah a game um
no that was it
ah so what zig said that i
was like i know what this is
about but also but also yeah hi
guys i have a game okay you've
got about a minute okay what do
we got i was thinking can't stop
eating so when it's really exciting for
a long time because i want um
the game is called would you rather
this is a game that we played
growing up my mom claims to have
made it up but now it's a
board game um but it's literally just
giving two options of either horrible or
great things then you pick which one
you would rather have and why and
you just go around that's it so
thing we play on bang man all
the time oh yeah my mom invented
that but oh wow
i'm not gonna painting language rather you
know that the non question version of
it i guess what do you mean
have you ever listened to my show
yeah but what are you talking though
i've been on enough that i think
i've played every game
what game would you rather
would you rather own bombay may all
i don't listen to it that much
always nice to meet a van paul
you guys don't come to my shows
why would i want to listen to
yours still made damn you got me
alright well i was thinking about the
melon show my mom because we were
doing things my mom did and that
was something we don't i was little
and we had like audio because what
kind of things would she ask you
about
like would you rather have she would
make them up and stuff oh great
would you rather have a pink convertible
with a lightning streak on the side
or would you rather have a piece
of my dna
like a really fast bicycle with streamers
on it you know i mean could
just make up anything but i think
it's fun if it's like well you
could probably sell the car for more
than a bike so um that's not
the question but also are you wait
are you really shocked that i don't
listen to comedy bang bang every week
no i just figured you would bid
on when
we played well that's why we thought
but i don't know if i have
okay um zig what's our what's our
three-tiered this episode
umm we can we have a list
we can do ah
ah cornell we can do the laughing
game when player says ha car next
player says haha what was well yeah
we already played that for yorker or
no we didn't what's the name is
so dumb that someone pointed a player
in ted's title the person on their
right has to say a new title
using the last word from the previous
person's title
oh we we just recently let's do
um the hugging yeah let's do the
hugin
hogwarts there's that cat again so it
but it's it's i don't remember explaining
it again yeah so one player says
huh next player says haha and so
forth first person to laugh loses
everyone is like i'm still chewing my
chocolate jumps she knew
yeah
i'm like burping in my chest
you can't make us actually
huh
ha ha
hahaha you have to look at the
person oh haha
hahahaha
ha ha ha ha hee
huh
ha ha ha hee
whoa
i left after my journey was done
but i don't know if i don't
know if that's true but it's your
birthday
ha ha ha ha ha hee ho
ho
hahaha hee ho ho hoo
you did a he too early is
that part of it i didn't she
added one no you you're supposed to
do for hawes megahy you did three
ah
don't think so i think this takes
away from those aged just pause but
then you added a heath doesn't get
fun last time we did it we
allowed other okay but i'm saying why
am i the keeper of the law
all i'm saying is if we truly
were playing that way then you just
lost but ok
haha why didn't she lose when she
added aha
you both lost great
your birthday no no no no no
no no no we're starting it was
four it was for hawes we're starting
t two hose
so here's we're starting over and it's
going from high voice to low voice
this is where adding another voice to
loop yeah okay
go figure
weight is a match mentality just as
high as you can go huh
huh
huh terrible huh
it's it's
you're laughing
huh huh huh huh
huh huh huh
huh
huh huh huh huh huh
huh huh huh
she's out
huh
whoa
back to you
huh huh huh huh huh ah ah
oh i'm out europe
huh huh ah ah ah ah ah
oh
huh huh huh ah oh ah oh
oh oh oh ha
oh yeah not using i
yeah you in paul are you guys
my family play would you rather even
though it was playing player do it
we could play on comedy version it's
not wise not comedy because because we're
showing kids it's it's all pee pee
poo poo yeah would you rather pee
pee or poop poop poop poop shower
no it's not no it's because your
show is gross so sometimes it's come
paul i'd never thought i'd hear you
ever say that rome find me guilty
started start a lower tom florin would
you rather wake up every day borrowing
or fall asleep everybody who's different
i'm just waiting no then what are
you starting out where you're comfortable okay
na fall asleep every night fighting big
thank you
you can ask guess i guess the
second one was the former
the former is barf every night yeah
there's really few things up every morning
surfing yeah i guess horrible well i
guess the farting is language youth
the farting is like bothers other people
more than bothers you but yeah i
don't want to ruin your marriage
so is morphing might do it too
is the thing though where like i
would be testing our marriage i think
this anything where like every morning i
wake up he can barf and hide
it but the farts he can't hide
it ruins his marriage i go to
the bathroom department just one bar
what do you mean i wasn't oh
yeah this is bad i've been throwing
up every morning for the last five
years
put your nuts i've been hiding it
from you okay fine you win no
ask yeah yeah there's no winner i
know alright asked me so scott yeah
would you rather be
invisible to the people that love you
and that's how you find out who
loves you or
or the people you hate are invisible
to you but they hate you who
i think it would be terrible to
be invisible to one person in particular
who loves me so your mom me
well that would be awful and i
don't really care who loves me or
who doesn't love me so that's not
like an enticement the finding out part
of it so i guess it would
have to be the other one where
like they're invisible do i still hear
them yeah ooh that's creepy and are
they whispering
that's all they talked about how much
they hate you and they know they're
invisible to me no they don't oh
well then i could hear what people
love but i don't even like knowing
what people think about me have you
seen that black mirror where you can
block people in real yeah oh my
god so good oh yeah those so
crazy yeah pretty crazy that's crazy but
fuckin blew my mind that's so bloom
with every episode
it's like the show every episode i
okay me so i'd say that i'd
say the second the second right everyone
would pick the second ah no not
me i'd like much rather be invisible
to the people
alright lauren
would you
like to go take a take a
trip to the moon with everything that
it entails like you'd have to train
you'd have to play among the stars
um it would take you you know
as long as it took them and
all that kind of stuff okay or
would you or would you
like to never achieve any more professional
success than you have at this moment
like you like basically everything dries up
at this moment and then you choose
whatever life that you would you would
choose if you were like oh this
whole thing is so either have to
go to the moon or everything dries
up yes so you're saying yeah that's
so
so that seems so grubby for me
to be like i'll go to the
moon
but this is why it's hard to
get to go to the moon this
is why it's a hard choice though
because like that seems like a lot
of work and a lot of time
it's a lot of work but i'd
become so famous from it would you
live beyond the moon people will go
to the moon new go to the
moon who's gone to the moon since
that's the thing i don't even know
has anybody gone has anyone been to
the moon i don't feel like they're
sending people regularly
we know they're there not for sure
i honestly the host the post office
goes there every every year just become
a male
why
why are they aliens yeah the aliens
know like i told you i actually
really don't want to go to outer
space it would be right i feel
like it would be frightening so i
think i have to accept the fact
that everything dries up as it is
and i have to get a regular
job i guess as a barista um
no
no i don't say boy that same
point she's maxed out at her success
level that doesn't mean she can't continue
working the same job no i mean
i mean the cheat
it it all i guess what i
meant as everything dries that everything is
yeah you have to pick another dyson
yeah i think about that sometimes it
doesn't seem kind of like cool so
yeah let's go do something else and
yeah ham to worry about this bullshit
thing but you and and you had
some success nominated for an emmy and
then i get to me none for
go work at the airport right and
you don't have to go to the
moon which i actually think i don't
want to go to the moon enough
that i don't think i would want
to go to the tow horrible i
would absolutely love none of them really
yeah just the sales and difficult force
and the one feel it you know
my favorite ride is that rye where
you're at to help you stand in
a big circle and later
full force i went on that i
went on that when i was young
and magic mountain and and i had
a very queasy stomach and still sort
of delicate little stomach and all that
people would tell you about was like
i vomited on my veil for short
pants her and i farted on it
turn to the side if you're gonna
throw up because if you've if you
throw up during the ride it'll come
back in your face wasn't there some
girl who was like scalped by that
right scalped yeah like her ponytail dot
cottons was it that riders some of
the road
the predator got her we do all
around yeah but go the opposite direction
yes yeah i once got yelled at
on that ride for what for to
having my phone out right before it
started i want to do a video
now bono phone my phone sound like
you're doing a photo what is what
was gonna happen
i wanted to take a little video
of me and my friends on the
ride and then this guy came on
the loudspeakers put your phone away and
i was mortified embarrassed as a grown
man on this children's ride yeah okay
let's go again we're going the opposite
way make it good this time make
a good okay good you're gonna scott
and the guy asked me
you walk into new york city walking
just walk in there
would you rather
you're getting mugged in new york city
with club and you have to fight
people to the death to protect her
wow where you actually kill someone but
you are right and you don't get
in trouble for it the meaning in
the second scenario oh i'm having gotten
to the second scenario oh oh oh
so so so i fight them to
the death i
when you kill someone kills someone occupy
but it's justified don't live with i
live with murder and you have to
do it yeah in what in what
way my first you are afraid but
it was justified in what way am
i doing it to them like by
banging their head against you killed them
with co-ops per shop and you like
like go run them sure
you tighten it around their neck until
their heads explode explode i want to
do that but they don't explode they
just suffocate slowly and it's kind of
like a little bit lame that you
did it like that but did
and because people like if you were
a man you would punch him in
the hat or something thanks and you're
like cool up give me your parents
and then you for spurs
purse me
and just like what no
just give me that purse honey
either that or i like that though
because it seems like you're just gonna
hit her purse over but it said
you turned into a murder weapon yeah
it's kind of cool yeah yeah to
you but no one no one else
thinks is still think so everyone calls
me the purse killer yeah the apes
the tapes tapes the papers shipping pro
pay
pair up when they set the pace
it's going to be bad news for
you or your other option is you
have to be a paparazzi guy for
the rest of your life and you
only follow john c reilly and you
have to get a picture of him
the farmer i want to kill someone
like my life is the same in
the form yeah yeah except you you
like have that was part of your
story you people have a hard time
over looking at
i mean people there are people certain
actresses who killed people in drunk driving
shoes and they're fine i think very
gayheart okay it wasn't sandy
matthew broader randy that's right matthew broderick
but
it does weigh on you and but
i feel like i always have dreams
where i've killed someone anyway and i
have to live with that guilt so
but just everyday waking up going oh
right i killed someone would be really
tough but you do it probably because
i don't want to follow right around
that would be worse
waking up every day going all i
do is probably the right day get
a picture of john c reilly every
day sol kills him one
okay okay i mean you'd have to
follow him around the world countries and
shooting movies and thing yes you own
island travel yeah yeah yeah joe skull
island
okay paul would you rather
sign up for a movie subscription service
where you um have to go to
a theater every day and see one
movie and stay all the way through
or else you have to give them
a hundred thousand dollars of your own
money it only do i want to
sign up for that you'll say you
signed up
for right so that's one choice so
either in that in that choice you
can make either of the choices like
use sure see a movie every single
day and you have to fit it
into your sketch if i give them
a hundred thousand dollars my done yes
yeah like they go okay no harm
no foul okay or would you rather
become a famous chef who ah has
his own cooking show
um and then ah accidentally during a
live episode is very very popular but
during a live episode um your pants
fall down around your ankles and everyone
says look at that but ooh outside
mama that's the audio thing
yeah that's someone in the audience and
it becomes like but what outside mama
see malviya and that becomes a catchphrase
and is sold on like t-shirts everywhere
and ah you become known as the
bud schiff
um i think the second one why
i think i got a pretty good
ass and ah proud of it
you wouldn't wanna go see a movie
every day
no every day no and i have
everything i have to watch the whole
thing yeah yeah it would really that's
worse you do you could do it
anywhere in the world though it's where
at least if i'm the bus chef
there's times where i'm not hearing and
seeing them
but knowing that i have you dream
about yeah you dream about it every
night our us shame i already do
so no problem yeah i guess i
get it okay alright okay your turn
why do they say out see mama
because he's there so turn they're so
turned on so yes see that's what
that's what i that's how i took
it that's why i'm like
a compliment to come there turned on
but they're weird they're considered to be
like a weird perf so no one
else has turned off they are considered
to be a weird perf yeah it's
an ironic sort of yeah thing like
keyboard like look at that weird perf
and that idiot who dropped his pants
on tv i think those people are
protesting too much okay alright let's say
that they're immortal barter into it they're
all in
do it yeah
paul urine scott no not me lauren
did you get seconds on your whip
cream and chucky boy bags i get
more whipped cream not more chocolate jacks
because the retails and now yeah the
ratio was in ultimate
lauren
would you rather be sightless but you
have the most beautiful singing voice or
hearing impaired and you compose the most
beautiful melodies and when i'm hearing impaired
am i completely deaf can i not
hear anything or am i just impaired
you can't enough okay
but your melodies you know that they
are you can hear it in your
head i think i would rather be
sightless melodies like la la la la
because i really valuing to get the
food out around like i gotta get
this one in
that's a great melody is beautiful how
about this one although
i'm actually not sure
because when i'm when i'm deaf i
can still see i'm going to sign
language
and i can do and i compose
amazing songs that everyone loves
when you're blind i don't know i
feel like i feel like being blind
made me bedroom to the to me
but yeah because i could listen to
the tv instead of read the caption
he listened to my podcast listen to
call me baby or one was doing
i don't really listen to comedy podcasts
i'll just put it out there great
also you would not know how many
chests that's mike is just being get
away with la constantly tripping i think
another show species oh that's my same
just said i'm sorry wow
let's see oh and i hear yours
communicate in that way you oh i
like to be i rather be blind
and be able to show my characters
and like like and like talk in
the same capacity that i'm able to
now and communicate with people the same
way and i think being here's the
thing no one wants you to do
that oh they don't want me to
sing now
you have a beautiful singing voice but
no one taught me the thing no
one likes your character people like when
people like when using okay so now
i'm just a singer but not really
so not for a job like i'm
just oh you you want it to
be your job turns hard i think
i'd rather be deaf than i guess
how good do you think you could
sing
if i was the in this scenario
just right now not amazingly at all
it's your little no do you sing
the raised by tv theme yes but
do you do all the parts a
yeah
um but ah except for the barbecue
sauce at the end yes that's gateways
which she's doing them i feel hey
really yeah yeah he can't he cannot
carry a tune at all he knows
a well he hits he hits it
right but it's just it's too high
you should try to sing a song
with him i will in general i
well you should just try it just
try
bubba usually he's the first to say
it but okay i put it up
this is really hard thank you you're
really struggling with this one i guess
i'm gonna have another look because i
guess i guess i would prefer the
second one so i could still do
comedy
um but i'm doing it with smilingly
look you're not doing comedy oh okay
yeah that's out of your head so
that is the larger your life is
over this is you have different talents
now okay then you're i mean you're
you're funny enough and i known for
like like like it's my previous life
part of the story or no no
everyone oh then
really be a blind singer
i would love to have an amazing
singing voice but if i were suddenly
a singer now and only a singer
i never did comedy i think people
would not take it seriously to be
very lame now everyone hated your comedy
so much they asked to be hit
in the head so they would all
have amnesia
but then they got hit in the
head again and then remembered alright good
i'll take that yea and that's how
high would you rather hear the figure
yeah bubba did i know i'm sure
i put down um that was fun
i wanna i'm very i was very
surprised by this whip cream chocolate chip
thing it's it was paul's idea oh
okay i was gonna bring doughnuts right
enough
how to you then thank you so
much he were talking it saved yeah
we were it was funny because we
were thinking of it at the same
time yeah lauren texted me and i
had just been thinking oh we should
get the whip cream wow i why
that was that was very meaningful to
me no one has ever surprised me
on my birthday with anything so thank
you very much o
rago really appreciate it um and ah
thank you for making this us ah
so wonderful oh we've already and happy
happy so ma mo you had see
mommy you would only know of nazi
mama
i'm so turned on i gotta go
alright we'll see next time thank you
everybody we love you i
a